sur mario paul toujours on attend un
coup de fil entre emmanuel macron et
poutine cet après midi à 16h30 nous dit
l'elysée au coeur de cette nouvelle
échange donc la situation humanitaire
dans cette ville d'après les ukrainiens
la guerre aurait fait là-bas entre cinq
et dix mille morts le président français
veut mettre sur pied dans les prochains
jours un corridor humanitaire en tout
cas les russes ont beau annoncer qu'il
se concentre sur le don bas c'est bien
de nouveaux bombardements ont eu lieu à
micola yves ce mardi c'est près de
dessin le bâtiment de l'administration
régionale a été détruit il y aurait là
bas cette mort 22 blessés jouit d'une
golf bonjour vous revenez d'une mission
de nicolas yves et on le voit donc les
russes continuent de pilonner cette
ville oui on y était à vendredi
précisément dans ce bâtiment
administratif 1 c'est le siège du
gouvernorat de la ville où notamment
travail vitaly khimki et le gouverneur
de micola iv que nous avions interviewé
précisément à l'endroit où ça a été
bombardé quand je dis précisément c'est
son bureau se trouve exactement à
l'endroit où la frappe a frappé donc on
voit bien que c'est à travers cette
frappe lui qui était visé c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'il dit sur sa chaîne
télégramme que les russes que l'envoi
des avertissements comme ça avait été le
cas un peu plus tôt dans la semaine ce
que nous avait dit vitali kim vendredi
lorsque nous l'avions interviewé c'est
que bien même si les troupes russes ont
reculé eh bien les bombardements sont
toujours aussi importants vendredi par
exemple y avait dix frappes qui ont
ciblé la ville où la banlieue de la
ville cependant et bien le gouverneur ne
souhaitait pas nous donner l'emplacement
ses frappes quand nous étions sur place
à nicolas yves donc la semaine dernière
le centre-ville a commencé à être
frappés ça c'était nouveau parce que
jusqu'à présent et bien ce les
bombardements touché plus tôt la
banlieue de micola yves et donc
plusieurs bâtiments étaient frappés dans
le centre-ville un hôtel un hôpital
psychiatrique
et puis plus plus important encore le
vendredi précédant le 18 mars il ya eu
énormément de morts amis collègues et 20
80 soldats ont été tués dans un
bombardement d'un site militaire donc
c'est une ville où on entend constamment
les sirènes résonnaient à la défense
anti-aérienne travailler et les
bombardements très régulièrement mais
contrairement à cette image la ville
n'est pas détruite ce contrairement
aussi à mario paul contrairement à
marioupol la ville n'est pas détruite
d'ailleurs lorsque j'ai interviewé
vitaly qui me vendredi avec amara la
médaille lui demander quel est votre
plus grande crainte monsieur le
gouverneur il m'a répondu que nicolas
yves n'existe plus je lui dis est ce que
vous pensez que c'est un scénario qui
est probable possible il me dit bien sûr
je lui ai demandé s'il pensait à mario
paul m'a dit évidemment je pense à
marioupol j'ai peur que mikko live soit
la prochaine marioupol mais quand on est
dans le centre-ville de nicolas yves les
rues sont assez désertes par ailleurs il
ya des obstacles antichar à peu près
partout des sacs de sable pour
barricader la ville cet immeuble
administratif par exemple était vraiment
sécurisé par une large zone et gardé par
des militaires on sent un peu de vie de
temps en temps entre deux sirènes ou les
gens tentent d'aller acheter des biens
de première nécessité mais on a vu au
également tous les jours on nous y
sommes allés énormément de gens
continuaient à quitter la ville 30 % de
la population a déjà quitté la ville et
à chaque fois nous y sommes allés nous
avons vu sur cette route qui relie
nicolas yves à odessa des convois de bus
de civils qui continuaient à partir et
je crois que les habitants de nicolas
yves sont plutôt russophone comment
est-ce qu'ils appréhendent cette cette
guerre écoutait vendredi j'ai interviewé
une dame une dame d'un certain âge 66
ans qui à qui je demandais quel était
son état d'esprit et elle l avait décidé
de rester dans la ville et elle a très
confiance dans l'armée ukrainienne qui
repousse petit à petit l artillerie
russe et elle m'a dit comment
voulez-vous je me sente madame je suis
russe et les russes ne bombarde et il
s'est mis à pleurer et elle est partie
et c'est vraiment le sentiment qu'on a
c'est que les gens ont l'impression
qu'ils se font bombarder par leurs
frères il ya énormément bien sûr
d'inquiétude d'appréhension j'ai
rencontré également une dame qui vit
depuis un mois dans sa cave parce que
son appartement les vitres ont été
soufflées il fait encore froid là bas
malgré tout même si le printemps est
arrivé donc impossible pour aller bien
sûr de rester vivre dans son appartement
donc depuis un mois les terré dans sa
cave on sent beaucoup d'angoissé
beaucoup
d'incertitudes aussi de la part de cette
population quand le centre-ville a été
touchée on a senti vraiment un
changement d'état d'esprit dans la de la
part de la population même si encore une
fois ils veulent vraiment croire et
s'accrocher à l'espoir du fait que ai
bien l'artillerie russes qui étaient aux
portes de la ville maintenant est un peu
plus loin selon vitali kim dont je vous
parlais ils sont à 20 km au sud est à 50
km au nord donc ils ont quand même été
repoussée mais on sent à la fois que un
état d'esprit assez étrange de la part
la population qui s'habitue petit à
petit à ces sirènes et qui en même temps
sursaute au moindre bruit comme
comme on peut bien imaginer merci
beaucoup je lis pour son compte rendu